- Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome.
- I'm Stephen Pitti, Professor
of History American Studies
and Ethnicity, Race in Migration.
And I'm also the director of
the Yale Center for the Study
of Race, Indigeneity, and
Transnational Migration.
It's wonderful to see so
many people here today
are with us for this
exciting conversation.
We're happy to host this conversation
about the first English
language translation
of Severo Sarduy's poems.
Keeping in mind, of course
that in talking about this XL Cuban author
those of us in new Havana are doing so
on the historical and
contemporary homelands
of many indigenous people and nations
including the Mohegan
Mashantucket Pequot,
Eastern Pequot, Schaghticoke,
Golden Hill Paugussett.
Niantic, Quinnipiac and others.
Our conversation today features
translator David Francis
who serves as Dean
of Grace Hopper College
here at Yale university
where he also teaches in
the program in ethnicity,
race and migration.
David's translations and poems
have appeared in inventory.
The FSG Book of Twentieth
Century Latin American Poetry,
Guernica, Exchanges, The
Brooklyn Rail, Poetry Daily,
The Chronicle of Higher
Education and elsewhere.
Professor Francis holds
an M.F.A in poetry writing
from Columbia University
and a PhD in Romans,
Languages and Literature
from Harvard university.
He received a Fulbright
to translate the poetry
of Colombian writer, Jose
Asuncion Silva into English.
And he is currently translating
a collection of poems
by the Cuban author,
Jorge Olivera Castillo
and another by poets from Northern Mexico.
As I already mentioned about
briefly, his translation
of Severo Surduy's poetry footwork
just published in 2021
by circumference books
is the first collection
of the Cuban authors,
poems translated into English.
David Francis will be
in conversation today
with Shawn McDaniel, a Terrific Scholar
who is currently assistant
professor of American studies
and ethnicity at the University
of Southern California.
Intersecting, Caribbean, Latin American,
and Latin X literary and cultural studies
and an intellectual history,
Professor McDaniel's research
explores, race, gender
sexuality, aesthetics,
modernism, and dissidents
in print, visual and Sonic
cultures at the Americas.
His first book, centenary subjects
race reason and rupture in
the Americas is forthcoming
later this year from
Vanderbilt University Press.
Professor McDaniel is
working on a second book
entitled Cuban Chic, Queer Deco,
and Diasphoric Modernism in New York,
which examines the literary,
graphic, sartorial, sonic
and cinematic cultures
of cubanidad in New York
as well as its inter-American
routes through Havana,
Santiago, Marida,
Veracruz and Los Angeles.
We are in the Yale
Center feel very honored
to be able to host this
celebration of David Francis
his translation of Sarduy's poems.
Let me think, the associate
director of Yale's ITM center
Matthew Tenneco for his hard work
putting author together
as well as center staff Maggie
Katz and Nicole Edwards.
And of course a great big thanks
to the Whitney humanity center
for co-sponsoring this event.
Now, let me encourage all
of you who are here today,
to submit your questions
to professor Francis
and professor McDaniel
by using the Q&A function here on Zoom.
It is a great way to be
in conversation with them.
I know that they would
love to hear your questions
about Sarduy, about Cuban
authors and other writers,
about translation and
about other relevant topics
that come up for you during the
course of this conversation.
So, please do use the Q&A function
to submit questions to them.
And we're really happy to
say that circumference books
the publisher of Sarduy's Footwork
has offered a discount
off for today's attendees
who'd be interested in
purchasing that book
cause I hope all of you are.
The discount code from circumference books
for this publication is going
to be posted in the chat.
If you know people who'd be
interested in this events,
but who aren't here
today who can't make it
for this conversation,
please do let them know
that this recording will
be on the Yale YouTube site
on the ITM playlist in the weeks to come
and that they can find it there.
And with that, I wanna thank all of you
for joining us today.
And I wanna turn the
microphone over with great joy
to professor David Francis
and professor Shawn McDaniel.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Steve.
And I'm just so elated to be here too
for the first public
celebration of the book.
And I am so much gratitude
to you, to Matthew Tenneco
to Shawn McDaniel, the Whitney
humanity center and RTM
for supporting this event.
So thank you very much.
I want to start with a brief
introduction to who Sarduy is,
reading from the first page of the book.
And then what I'll do is
give a sort of Panorama
of poems that I translated
from the beginning of the work to the end.
And that should take about 20 minutes.
And then I really can't
wait to, discuss the poems
and questions that everyone
has about the translations,
about Sarduy of the book
afterward with Shawn.
So, that will be coming soon.
The scarred body or the
image of its absence,
faced with the question
of how to translate
the body of Sarduy's poetry.
I feel a sense of stuttering.
How to convey the enormity
of seeming contradiction,
I encountered about
translating this poems,
indeed a body of work
that seems on its own
that celebrates the kind of
life essential experiences
of dance, of painting, food,
music, and sexual pleasure.
But that also recognizes
in these pleasures
the imminence of one's passing.
And is 56 years of life,
the exiled poet, novelist,
essayist, painter and
world traveler managed
to include such a vast
range of perspectives
and poems in his texts.
That in the process of selecting
which poems to include in Footwork,
I wanted to offer a survey
of his life as a poet,
from his earlier pieces
to those he composed
near the end of his life.
So, Sarduy was not known
to follow convention.
Nor did he think that
conventional approaches
to storytelling or lyrical composition
could capture the
complexities of human behavior
or personal and national identity.
The publication of his
major works followed
the Cuban revolution and
the political turmoil
that would ensue with the El Paso's rise
in Cuban dictator Fulgencio
Batista's loss of power in 1958.
As boom literature
galvanized by such authors
as Mario Vargas Llosa, Julio
cork DASA in colors Wednesdays
brought Latin America
increasing visibility
in the world, literary stage.
This gay author and artist
son of a railroad worker
redefined Latin American approaches
to the writing of literature
from the vantage point
of his exile in France
and from many other parts
of the world he visited
after departing his country of birth.
Born in 1937 in Camaguey Cuba,
Sarduy started writing as a young man.
Publishing in his teenage years in various
Cuban literary magazines
between Conaway and ranup.
After pursuing studies in
medicine in Cuba's Capital,
he left the Island on
a scholarship in 1960
to study art criticism in Europe,
traveling to Madrid and then to Paris.
Aware of Castro's efforts
to police homosexuality
and re-educate gay men
and work camps called
military units to aid production,
Sarduy would reside for the
rest of his life in Paris,
never to return home.
So do we achieve considerable notoriety
before his life was cut short
in 1993 to publications eight?
The author's first novel Gestos Gestures
was published in 1963.
But the book by which
he is most recognized
is the novel De donde son los
cantantes published in 1967.
An experimental work of fiction
that Suzanne Jill Levine
translated definitely
into English as from Cuba
with a song in 1972.
Internationally celebrated for his work,
Sarduy won Francis
prestigious Prix Medicis prize
for his novel Cobra,
which came out in 1972.
Sarduy published extensively
on his novels and essays
and continue to write about his poetry.
Sarduy works contained
often chaotic convergence
of linguistic registers and characters
whose bodies just in
drug, tattooed or scarred,
distort, reconfigure or explode
in Big Bang fashion or in little deaths,
bourgeois efforts to codify
or define a singular
Latin American identity.
And what ensues I wish to share a series
of poems from his earliest works
to those he wrote near
the end of his life.
In doing so in preparation
for my conversation
with professor McDaniel,
I hope to illustrate not only some of
Sarduy's masterful formal renderings,
but also the expansiveness
with which he wrote into his works
fast geographies of art, philosophy,
science, desire and
determinations on death
and the life of writing.
Now, I think I will be
sharing a visualization
of the poems I will be
reading just so that everyone
can get a sense not only of the language
that Sarduy is using, but
also the brilliant ways
in which he plays with poem on the page,
which is much more difficult to convey
just by reading his poems out loud.
So, I'll begin with a poem of Sevillanasa.
It's from an earlier
Chatbook type Flamenco,
since its first Chatbook
that came out in 1969
but it was republished inside his book
called Big Bang in 1974.
And there's a series of poems in this book
dedicated to different forms
of Flamenco (indistinct).
So, this form of dance that
we'll be reading about here
is called the Sevillanas.
Sevillanas.
In the white SPACE, where
shadows are unrolled,
light goes gnawing at the borders,
folding the colors, destroying the forms,
IN THE WHITE SPACE, crossing over from
the other side of the
band of light, bursting in
without limits (without shadows)
sphere
yellow rectangle, green stains
triangle, convergence of the iris
pieces whose marble is
hardly visible are drawn,
are won over once more by the
light, decomposed, expelled
from the page, disjointed
figure, extinguished, that
IN THE WHITE SPACE, an instant later
goes insinuating its forms,
creating fringes of color,
defining their borders, appearing
while the excessive light
withdraws:
a head,
a squared saffron, blue and green ovals,
a prism,
a segmented body.
White.
So I will move forward to another chatbook
that came out originally
in 1970 MOOD INDIGO
which follows Duke Ellington's
epidemic album called
mood Indigo and read a
poem within that book.
It's also published in the
re-publication of the Big Bang.
But this poem is called Echoes of Harlem.
Echoes of Harlem black Panthers
with shut shutters
with planks standing doors,
with bags of sand and broken mirrors,
and amulets locking windows,
incantations, murderwhite
Jean Genet in a forgotten suitcase,
machine guns
everything that must be broken
Echoes of striped Harlem
Cyclone,
little hash cakes,
Zero
Nina at the piano.
Everything must be destroyed,
the next time fire.
So as we move forward, I
won't be reading this poem
but just to offer again,
another sense of how much Sarduy
in his earlier works is playing with form.
I show you here Hong Kong Indigo,
and it's taking the shape of a spiral
and referring to a
number of musical venues
in the history of Jazz music
played in different
venues Transatlantically.
But I would like to
move on to the next call
that comes from Big Bang
which is essentially about Sarduy's,
obsessive thought about
the theory of the Big Bang
as the creation of the universe
but also as sort of this staddling
this figure standing in
for, or erotic desire
or the encounter to lovers
and many other things.
So much of Sarduy's, celestial
knowledge is encapsulated
in these beautiful poems
about celestial bodies
and heavenly bothered me is another term
to discuss one of these ideas
Heavenly Body
The weight of your body on my body
saturing skin ciphered
Green saliva on your back
spine on spine,
knees knotted
speared with phosphorescent lacquer
the bones
light up the black walled room
volumes articulating
I'embottoast
entering in silence
greased, slowly
each in another
radiance, descending
over the wall along the
distance of the wall
dead asters falling
to the sheets marble
This Palm concludes the
translation of Big Bang
and really much of
Sarduy's experimental work
with form.
But it doesn't conclude
his brilliant renderings
of new sorts of language that
goes into very traditional form
and in a fleeting and masked witness
which came out in 1985.
We see a series of
really beautiful sonnets,
heavily evocative of
homoerotic desire and sex.
And so one of these poems I'd like to read
they're all untitled, but
opening up with this book
is one of these beautiful
sonnets with the first one
called the Murmur of Machine's was rowing.
The murmur of machines was growing
in the adjacent room already; my hope
for an adjective or for your body
was nothing more than an
attempt to shorten the day.
The night was arriving and proceeding
the desert wind, the certain
light... or your naked feet on the mat...
of sunset, was suspending time.
I do not remember love only desire;
not the lack of faith, only the sphere...
the image facing its reflection
with white texture, the true
page _or your body, which I still recread
vast, idiogram of spring.
Another example of
Sarduy's, obsessive work
with not only the sonnet form
but with sound with
this subsequence on it.
Not the voice proceded by the echo,
nor the ravenous reflections
of the naked bodies
in the quicksilver of the quiet crystals,
but this simple brushstroke, dry:
the fruits on the table
and the colonial landscape.
When the hour of the siesta was
enveloped us in the density
of itself swelling seas,
or in the murmur of it's ended fiesta,
When one in the other extinguished thirst,
when light advanced
through the orchard that
the flame tree reddened,
we opened then the great door
to the insular murmur of noon
and to the timely still life.
The final sonnet I'll be
reading from this section.
Pull out of me more
than what was left out;
for when reaching and defining aporia
a planet on the other side its day
ignites the sight of its senses.
Not by force, for the humid temple
(of Venus, the second)
does not take pleasure
in being wounded by the
Bersinian arrow or by frenzy.
Someday you will lay lubricants
or natural substances
between the borders with cunning prudence,
or with salivated caution
that might ease the
burning of your entrance
because with love and with ardor
in the annals of history
our naturals are ciphered.
Nearing the end of Severo Sarduy's life,
we see another publication of sonnets
which I've translated as the title of
a PERENNIAL AND BETRAYED
WITNESS that comes out in 1993.
But I'd like to focus in this section
of the reading or the conversation.
On Sarduy's(indistinct) with DECIMAS
which different from the
side is an even more compact
poem of 10 lines and a very strict drawing
which was not reproducible in Spanish.
But in my work, in renderings
is that DESIMAS into English.
I did do my best to convey
the sense of compactness and musicality.
So the first series of DECIMAS is,
comes from a series of poems
called the Crown of Fruits.
Cherimoya
Who hasn't tried a cherimoya
in the shade of a Red Manjack tree?
Denae weaves and undoes
time in gold and rum,
sickly sweet and sugary
for the inexperienced tongue;
neither green nor ripe
the palate takes delight.
Fruit, no, hope of the fruit.
Pleasure: but pleasure standing still.
I like to read now that
DECIMA number four,
called Pineapple.
I placed a bald pineapple
on three Chinese oranges,
and added in the corners
the sweetest guava.
In this way, in exile,
the insular queen crowns, baroque,
her still life -little-
and death which I've offered her.
And the emblem that it evokes.
There will be no pain no
more pain or oblivios."
Finally from the series,
Cashew.
However you close the mouth,
the tasty cashew,
acidic and then sweet,
turns your palate upside down.
If you spill the juice
is of little matter.
A sudden, idle drama,
a light fright
when its red hangs higher than
the hummingbird, than fire.
The last DECIMA.
I like to read from a
different series of DECIMA's,
comes from a series dedicated to Orishas
which Sarduy has dedicated
to Jorge and Miguel Barnet
to THE Los Orishas En
Cuba the book written by
Natalia Boliver Arostegui
and of course to Lydia
Cabrera and Pierre Farsumbi.
While I will be reading from this series
the final one titled Yernoja.
Mother of water, new Moon, a dove, a lamb,
I will offer to the austere sea,
that I might pass this test.
With life comes death.
A cross of white vuscarilla,
over the yellow forehead.
You will write my final breath.
And against tide and wind I'll row.
Until I reach the other shore.
Following Sarduy's death
came the publication
in 1999 of his La era neobarraca.
And this is one of the
most brilliant poems
I think in his work,
particularly due to what
he does with the poem.
And if, as you read in
here, the poem in English
you'll notice that this poem,
which is dedicated to the
Letters of the Alphabet
actually follows the letters
of the alphabet from ATC.
Each line begins with that letter
and also ends with that
letter and subsequent
and this series that follows each other.
So I will read this beautiful
column in the most form.
To the Letters of the Alphabet.
Arden's letter, your
blood will be ephemerra,
brief, like flowers of the baobab,
creating words that other letters (sic)
drop from, a ruse blundered.
Elsewhere, writing was an another empire
fragment, crib, knot, raga and kif.
Grave, thunder of a golden gong,
hint and reflection of an ancient aleph;
image that the space gives of its own.
Joining together letters, sun and haj,
..Kafka finds himself with his double, K
lackadaisical writing of
a rumor that's lethal..
Hano filled, combined
in the words of lull.
Maliarme doesn't forget
this, nor does Islam
nor the monk who taught in the monsoon
or he who wrote with letters and prayed,
Oh, Piet Mondrian prints
listening to be bop.
Question: Who is Duchamp and who HOOq?
Reflected in the trivial and the stellar
signs, silences do we not see the shadow?
Or is there indeed all the
being of light, as in Rembrand?
Universe of letters where you,
view painted cities Tel Aviv,
Westminster by Monet, the gray Glasgow;
xylography of the crude Sfix.
Ye, here is signature; Severo Sarduy...
Zagging, left-handed
algorithm of stubborn glitz...
Geneva 8-8-88.
So the final poem that I like to read
come from a time when we started
we was well aware of his own
eminent passing in writing
epitaphs both to himself about himself,
but about his friends as well,
who were also dying of AIDS.
Epitaphs.
One.
Here lies, deaf and severe,
he who used so many shoes, soles,
whose tips he abused from
the front and from behind.
Laconic adagio... and soothsayer...
Inscribe on his tomb
the skeleton crumbles,
gold of jewels undone
his name, and between two dates,
"the dead man's out to dance".
Five.
Death, you are so lazy in
delivering your sentence
here rests your witness.
It astonishes, and even delights
to see you labor, to see you scarce,
to see your disappearance with
the pleasure of surrender,
your siege of ash hounding
the funny vertebrae,
that's your way of being.
Six.
Savage, like the lashing
of rags and putrefaction.
Death's violent gob of spit.
There's no embrace more
faithful or long-term
two dates as Stroud of
dry and brief design
my confession and abomination
jewel, colophon, and emblem
of the buroque funeral.
Six.
At my funeral, may there be
cheese and guava and music;
May the mortuary protocols
be abridged and limited.
No excessive lamenting.
No bach, light music.
Play La Sanora Matancera.
For good taste, colors
don't lay flowers on me
If, on the highway, I die.
I realize there's some numbering
issues here in the edition.
This was six and the final one was seven
but that ends the reading.
And now I'll stop sharing the screen.
And I welcome conversation
questions about these poems.
The process of translating
them and anything else as well.
- Great, thank you so much, David.
Thank you.
I'll just be brief and say
thank you to the organizers
of this event expedition
to all the sponsors.
We really appreciated and thanks.
Most of all, of course, you to the public
for being here via Zoom.
We wish we could celebrate
this in person, of course
but this is, we're
working with what we got.
So, it's a real pleasure to be here
with all of you and I'll just get started.
I will also encourage you
to submit questions you have in the chat.
We'll get to those.
We'll be plenty of time for the Q&A.
We have such a good showing here today
which we appreciate and also see
a lot of people in the know
who work on the side of doing it,
who have made important contributions
to sort of the way scholarship, et cetera.
So we look forward to
your questions as well.
I guess I can just get, start out off
kind of in a general sense,
David, if you could just kind of tell us
a little bit, you know,
what possesses somebody to
translate, how to do it?
You were talking about
sort of this obsession
or this obsession,
obsessive method that he had
with sort of revisiting, you know
the sonnet and these different things.
While I would imagine that
that kind of obsession
probably also falls on the shoulder
of a translator of Sarduy as well.
So if you could maybe just tell us kind of
what gets you started down this path.
- Thank you, Shawn.
I fell in love with Sarduy's,
poems from the beginning.
I, you know, from the first
moment I encountered them.
I found a small edition of poems,
also published in the
eighties called (indistinct)
I was a master's program in Spanish
at the University of Virginia.
And they give you contributed also
to the 1985 publication that
I just was reading from.
And these brilliantly complex on it.
And I thought, Oh, these
I know the sonnet form.
I love that anyway.
And I thought it would be
a super accessible (laughs)
when this was my first
encounter with this poem.
And I found very quickly that
that was absolutely not the case,
but something about his
ability to infuse language
with so many things happening at once
was really compelling with me,
(indistinct) is composed
of only eights on it
but they're all extremely homoerotic
and all at the same time,
very subtle in some ways
and very outrageous and
hilarious in other ways.
So I just became obsessed
from the beginning
and I had to read more
and then I stayed with
the sonnets initially.
And then I found these other
brilliant formal renderings
that I thought would be important to share
with his work too.
He never stuck with only one form who's
who was experimenting throughout his life
with how language could convey
some of his central obsessions
but in different ways
on the page and vocally.
I thought this was something
that had to be shared primarily
because so much of this is on his novels,
but there should be greater
attention to his poetry as well.
- Yeah, I mean, you
know, it's this formal...
This aesthetic
experimentalism that defines
a lot of his work
and the fact that there
are so many, as you said,
this plethora of expressive
modes, registers, repertoires
that co-exist them and all of his work.
And, you know, thinking
about how you meaning
is so embedded in the language itself.
Can you share with us sort of
how you approach these
linguistic points of contact
or maybe these dissonances is probably
a better way to frame the question
as opposed to points of context?
I think that's something
that would be really
interesting people.
Cause I know that's
something that was on my mind
when I had heard that
you had translated
(indistinct) started Louie.
I immediately had a bunch
of questions of like
what are the exigencies, what
are the logistics of doing so?
What are the high points the
low points, the challenges,
I think if you could walk
us through some of that
I think that people would be
really interested about that.
- Oh, that's a great question.
I, the dissonances were wonderful
and maddening at the same time.
So, an example would be the
poem whose first line is
pulled out of me more.
It's not like that exactly in Spanish.
There's a pun going on in that first line
that is both upon beckoning the other
towards some sort of physical encounter
but at the same time,
distancing him or herself
from that other person.
But you don't see that
in the formal writing
of the burst alone,
you have to read the first line out loud
and you hear within that first line
there's a pun of being articulated
of OMI domain landmass.
So stay away from me
and also make the main landmass
and invitation to sexual encounter.
So this was something
I had to hear out loud.
And one of my first
conversations about this poem
was a brilliant scholar
who stumbled Pantheon
who I was working with
in a translation workshop
with whom I discussed this problem.
And I think I spent way too many years
trying to find a line that would work,
and finally decided that there
was obviously no perfect line
in the English (indistinct).
So I was doing at the same time
in all of my working with
the sonnets, especially
but also the DECIMAs.
I attempted at least to
infuse the poem still
with some sort of English
version of the sexual innuendo,
but also with rhyme music, et cetera,
so that you can get a sense
of play also in English.
- Yeah, and it's, seems
like a tall order, right?
I mean, it seems like a very,
not only delicate process
a maddening one, an obsessive one,
but a tall one at the same time, right?
So, I'm wondering...
When I talk about Sadury's
I always end up with this kind of loop.
There's always this sort of circularity
going on with me, where
I'm trying to kind of
talk about all the topics
that he's broaching
within a short span.
And so, I mean, how, you know
considering this vast array of
again, repertoires, registers
you know, that spans or
this cosmic, every addition
if we think of Big Bang
or the full black hole,
but also at the same time,
these sort of very deeply intimate realms
of the poetic subject,
can you share your thoughts about
how you navigate kind of the mundane
and the metaphysical at the
same time in his poetry?
- Right, but I think
that it takes a long time
with his work to sort of try
to figure out what he's doing.
So, suppose to read a lot of his poems
and read all of them
and get a sense of his
more global obsessions
but also to get a sense
of how in each poem
he's playing with the reader.
So if we were to go
back to that same sonnet
pull out of me more,
I initially became so
obsessed with the first line
that I neglected to pay
attention to the broader.
So let's talk about aporia,
which comes up in the second line,
which is pointing to attention
between two distinct ways
of viewing the same thing.
And it became apparent to me
that the Sonic was not
only a very funny sonnet,
but one, an invitation and
instructions to the reader
to go into the poem deep
deeply and to extract meaning
from it and from different perspectives.
So pull out of me more was
when I finally landed on,
because I realized that
much of Sarduy's poems
were instructions to me as
a reader and as a translator
to understand this
philosophical dissonance
between life and death,
between being and non-being,
between physical encounter
and the metaphysical sentiment
behind desire and how
at the end of one's life
which is what...
I think you see at the sort of like
experience of orgasm, right?
Cause Big Bang or little
debts at the end of the poem,
there's this realization
of one's eminence and imminent passing.
And that at least if there's
a sense of an encounter
between two people
that is sealed with the
naturals of desire and love,
that's where one's history can be written.
So, I don't know if that's a
direct answer to your question,
but I found in Sarduy's poem
both maddeningly difficult complexities,
but also a deeper philosophical troubling
of one's existence and the
fact that one's identity
can never be fully defined
except through dissonance
and through the
philosophical complications
that can never be resolved,
but still can be pointed
to through language
and through music.
So my work was really to
find ways to celebrate
that language through music
and in trying to do that in English.
- Definitely, you know,
I'm hearing that the last
thing you were saying
I'm wondering how much the title
you'd selected for this collection.
Footwork applies not only Sarduy's poetry,
but your translation of them as well.
Can you kind of just talk
us through that title
a little bit?
- Yeah so I am, the title
is really hard (indistinct).
None of it's,
none of the individual
titles have his books
seemed appropriate for the
full collection of his work,
of his words.
And, so many of his sonnets were untitled.
So they lacked sort of names
to sort of enter into
and you just sort of began reading them.
And, so I was going back
to his earlier works
which I think I've received
the least amount of attention
and notice there was so
much emphasis on dance.
And, then notice that
this is sort of permeated,
you know, not only the...
All the many different references
to types of dance Flamenco
and stuff and Viviana's,
and in other forms of dance,
but it was what came out
in his final epitaphs.
And the one who should
choose soles were worn thin
because there was so
much dancing in his life.
So, I thought, why not
something referential to feet
that not only sort of the
Keith that are dancing,
but also the the sort of formal renderings
that he was taking up in so many poems
through him decades syllabic
verse through DECIMAs
and really honored sort of his work
with the form of the
body and with the feet
that creates his mind.
- Wow, that's great.
Thank you.
Thanks for sharing those thoughts
and just the idea of music or dance,
of the somatic movements,
musicality, theatricality
all of these things converge
in his work of course,
but I'm wondering sort of
one of the most compelling parts I think
has to do with Jazz which you read
or you showed us one of
the formal poems, right?
And I'm just wondering, you know
how are you thinking moving forward
about music inside of this poetry?
I mean, particularly with respect to like
the poems about Harlem
and Jazz and, you know
like SPI mega is one of the
poems you put up, right?
Mood in the go, I'm just wondering sort of
how you read that larger sort
of transnational conversation
that's happening around black aesthetics
and sort of the work that
he's done in his prose,
for example,
and in this poetry as well
about Afro-Cuban culture,
you know I'm just kind
of wondering how you read
sort of transnationally
those elements in his poetry.
- All right, and I,
really love that question
because there has been
some scholarship on it,
but I would love through
these translations
to bring greater attention
to Sarduy's earlier
to obsessive work with
music through poetry.
And also has attention given to rights.
From Cuba with a song is the classic novel
that those who studied Cuban
literature will go back to
to talk about Sarduy's
own and Cuba's origins
of the African slave trade,
but also Chinese labor
but also the history of Spain in Cuba,
on the Island and not a
really does a lot of good work
to point to those concerns.
But what Sarduy's is doing and mood Indigo
is bringing greater
attention to musical poems
as they travel from one
geographic location to another.
So what's really interesting
about mood Indigo
and it's being all negative
is the gaps in knowledge
that you can't see as
easily in the pros, right?
So he's actually using
the form of the poem
to show these geographic leaps
that music has managed to transcend
between different musical
tenures Paris, New York,
and then create at the
same time wide space
around which history and
narrative can't be read.
So as much as surgery is writing about
the history of musical form,
he's also writing about how that history
through sort of violent eruptions inform
can never be fully accessed.
One of the reasons I couldn't
really read it on a reading.
You have to appreciate it on the page.
- Definitely, yeah.
And just sort of, just
kind of thinking on that,
what do you know about sort
of started doing this practice
of like reciting the poems that he wrote
or what kind of spaces did
they exist in public private?
I don't know if you have any information
that details about that.
- That's a great question.
I mean, there's some
interviews of him online
where he honors the
history of style and music.
And I think he was a brilliant WordPress
pre-site his deseamos
brilliantly, but I actually don't.
I haven't been able to
find any of his readings,
and they don't know of him.
You know going to venues and
giving like poetry readings.
If someone in the audience does,
I would love to hear about that.
And, but I think that's
a really great question.
So much of is sort of the criticism on him
is dedicated to the novels, but__
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
Yeah, absolutely.
And so, going off that as well, you know,
this is another reason
why the intervention
you're making is so
important is that you know
brings other kinds of
readings that Sarduy's opens
Sarduy's up to different
kinds of audiences.
But there was also something,
you know, like you said
this sort of inevitable gesture to go back
to the pros or the predominance
of the pros, right?
Of its pros versus the poetry.
And so I think something
I was very interested
in learning about, because I
know Sarduy's pro much better
than it was poetry and the same case
could be made about other
Cuban writers as well.
And not, nobody knows, for example.
You know how do you
situate Sarduy's poetry
within the landscape of
Latin American poetry?
What are some other poets
that he is sort of engaging
with riffing off of?
Or how can you read them in the context of
with respect of other
Latin American poets?
Because I see the formal experimentalism
I was thinking like, they
kind of what a Potter, right?
Like this anti-poetic kind of Praxis.
And I'm just wondering if you kind of,
would use that paradigm to
or how you would sort of think
through his poetry in a larger context.
- Yeah, I love that question
because he does play with form on the page
and so does know how to plan it up.
But at the same time,
as you sort of enter into the sonnets
you get a sense of his
deeply embedded devotion
Thehe Baroque and to
writers like Raylon Lorena's
but also to Spanish Baroque,
how it's like KBA though.
And which is why his
sonnets are so complicated
because he's at one time using
this really high register
of rhetoric where what, like one noun
is connected to him
for like the next step.
And, it was supposed to figure out
what the sentence is,
meaning syntactically.
And at the same time
there's a low register pun
going on there about a sexual encounter.
So some (indistinct) is, you know,
obsessed with St. John's across
with many of the Spanish Baroque poets
but also on a putting on love rhinos.
But you haven't had solid,
I think is in the background there too,
but also approve and poet
when there's a poem about blows and life.
That is so reminiscent of one of six of
my most famous poems,
but it's also talking
about lows of life, but
when you read it in cyber,
it's calm, it's, almost, you hear
but you also care like kind of a joke
about making the blows of life.
Not really something to
worry about that much
because it's just one of
those things that happens.
And this projected problem,
I'm thinking about a
flawed sexual encounter
that just goes bad.
And it's like, Oh, well
that happens sometimes.
- (Laughing)
- And, you know, thinking
about say somebody
in a different way now, too.
(laughing)
He's yeah.
He's thinking of all these writers
and he's also working with
the canonical boom writers
at the same time, right?
He helps bring Mr.
Somebody on a hundred years
of solitude and into French.
So he's got all of these authors in mind
as he's situating his
own verse and in novels
on a much more international landscape.
- Great, thank you.
That helps because that's, again
one of the really exciting parts
about your contribution
here that, you know,
it's giving some more entry points
inside of the East poetry, right?
It's sort of propelling us,
even those of us who do
read side of the weeds pros,
to maybe spend some more time
and attention with this poetry.
I have many, more questions
that I could talk to you about,
but honestly, the chat is blowing up
and I think it would be
really great to give some time
to some people's questions.
So I'll just, I'll pick a few out
to get us going here
and thank you to all of you
for submitting questions.
(indistinct) don't know if you can see
the chat function, David
but I'll read them out loud
so everybody can hear
such incredible work.
David, could you say a bit
about Sarduy's life in Paris?
Was he influenced by French
poets will layer et cetera
or maybe in conversation
with work by (indistinct)?
- Oh, I love that question.
He was very much embedded
in French culture.
He, his partner principal
was a philosopher
and he they were partners
very early on time
in Europe until the end of Sarduy's life.
And so his time spent in
Paris was very much embedded
in and post-structuralism
and deconstruction.
He worked with (indistinct) well,
he knew Judiac Kristeva,
this really cool photo of him
in conversation with Chris Deva at a cafe.
And if you've seen this photo
you know what I'm talking about?
It's like her statements in the center,
but the side like looking
inside these directions
I think that's sort of like emblematic
of this really interesting
moment in French theory
at in sort of reason conversation
with BARR, Roland box
at the same time, because there,
and in so much of his
poetry is you can see
this influenced by his sort of
understanding that the
ways in which language
only can provide a partial
understanding of one oneself.
So yeah, he's, aware of
all these French writers
that this questionnaire is bringing up.
And, but he's also sort of
writing out the philosophy of
deconstruction in his columns
which adds another really
frustrating complications
translating them and grounding them
in the physical body
that comes out as well.
- Well, let's keep those
frustrations of translation
going with this next question then
because from Emma says,
I highly enjoyed to the
letter of the alphabet
since your translation is also.
Is that Ariane?
(indistinct) what was your
experience of translating
words from Spanish to English,
while confined to the same first letter?
Are there any words you had to replace
her translate directly?
- That was so hard, but
it was really fun too.
And I don't, I think
maybe I have a problem.
Like, I loved the competition of
not knowing how to make this work,
but Sarduy's must've had so
much fun writing that poem
or even just the date itself 8-8-88.
I don't think he might not have written it
all on that same day, but
it says I entered the text
with a sense of playfulness and devotion,
more so you write to the series of letters
at the beginning of the
poem starting each line,
but also at the end.
So, when you read it
again, you will notice
that there were some
aberrations and at the same time
I tried to sort of stick
to more so to the form
so that you could see
this working in English.
One of the aggravations that you'll see is
I just couldn't get an O at the end
of the line with the first
word, the line began.
What does that word, okay?
I don't remember, but
the last line you'll see.
The last word is not the
letter of, it's the word out.
So, or he wrote, or he who
wrote with letters and prayed.
Oh, if you can think of a word
that like ends with O and
would make sense in that line,
give me a call and we'll talk about it.
That would be really fun
to think of another way
of translating the poem
but it was really hard to
make sense of that line
where the that ended, Oh.
So I just thought of the action of praying
rather than trying to
end the line with, Oh
I did sort of like a homophonic joke
to the sound of one might say, right?
So that's one of the aberrations is there
but you're right to point that out
also in the English language,
there's no like double L
but I couldn't extract
that from on either.
So it was kind of freeing in a way
to add another letter
to the English alphabet.
- I love hearing about the
methodology of translating
in these, (indistinct)
Next question is coming
from Andy I'd fund.
So somebody who knows a
thing or two about Sarduy?.
Also aside from the experimental poetry
that we've been talking about
are there more political
poems that directly referenced
or allude to the context of the revolution
that Sarduy somewhat escaped
and that you briefly described
your intro to the talk?
- That is a really great question.
I'm thinking back to a
poem, it didn't read,
but it's called Havana sex tech,
and it's a poem in six parts.
And it's really sort
of like this nostalgic
about asking where did all of
these things that were part
of a previous Cuba Co,
and those are there
many cultural references
in the poem that you just
kind of have to know.
And that if you don't know them,
it makes the poem spit
initially less penetrable.
But one of the references is
to a Trapeze artist called check-in ballet
and who tragically fell from...
He's walking across the tight rope.
And he, this is a real guy.
And he looks down at well.
So the myth goes, he looks down
at this beautiful woman
who he's in love with
and he sees her kiss someone else.
And so he is distracted and he falls
and his body is named and
he can never participate
in this brilliant art, which he's so good.
Again, he becomes, you
know, like a police man.
And so I had no idea
what this word was at all
until I had to go, I had to Google it.
And I wrote Rebecca to ask
do you know anything about
this cultural reference?
And then he sent me a Cuban radio show
talking about it and the myth that he,
that his name encapsulates.
And so just that one word sent
me down like a rabbit hole
of just being obsessed with
what started Wes' lines
and his earlier poems were doing.
And I think he really
was thinking at the time
how can I think of write about this place
that is no longer the same
and sort of honor the musicality of Cuba
and these open fares
of circuses and dances
and all of these things and sort of ask
where they've gone, yeah.
So, yeah, I don't know
if it's a direct political reference,
but it's in this, it's
a nostalgia imbued poem
about what has been lost
from the history of Cuba.
- Great, thank you.
Thank you for your question.
Thanks for your answer, David.
I'm gonna to go to Aleksandra next.
They say...
I noticed that at least
frequent use of specific colors and poems.
I was also thinking something similar
that the function of nouns, right.
There was a lot of...
A lot has been written about
the word bloom months, right?
And they almost want
to combine this, right?
So I'm just wondering
sort of what along with
Aleksandra question here
what kind of weight do these
nouns that perhaps reappear
or presences, like (indistinct)
I'm just sorting how that kind of figures
into your process or that, you know
how you read that in fact, these work
but for Alexandra specific question.
I know this I think these frequent use
of specific colors in his poems,
especially the color white
he seemed to like white
for specific foods.
To what do you attribute
his use of particularly
strong colors for example,
in his blank pages, poems.
- Alexander, I think
that's a great question.
You probably know this
but Sarduy also a painter and
he was obsessed with color.
I believe there's one line in
an interview of his that he
where he says colors cure and
he was obsessed with sort of
the meaning behind color
and which brought him also
to his obsessive mystical thinking about
the work of Rothko's paintings.
And so that was very much
part of his life to use.
He's a really, I think,
a brilliant painter
and you can find his work
in the Princeton Firestone
archives and go see them.
And they're beautiful.
So, not only was he writing
about color that he was painting
these formal works that were
often obsessed with circles
and in squares and then
Lipsey's and rectangles.
And there's a lot you can say
about this, but one of them,
one of the things that you can say
is related to white space and black space.
So if you see in the sort
of like the black spiral,
Sarduy was obsessed with
the sense of negative space
in finishability, but also of debt.
So I believe some criticism by again,
Roberto (indistinct)
points to the fact that,
and in your Roma, white means death.
So there's this sense of
history being interviewed
by the presence of death in
black spiral food Indigo.
But if you look at other poems
you also see sort of thing.
I mean, celebration of orange, red,
thinking back to the Sonic about Rothko
and some other colors too.
Many of the poems are
about still lives, right?
Either directly or indirectly.
So he's painting the life of a figure
in a sonnet while it's
also just still there.
So what's beautiful about
the translation of English
of Spanish to English was
that, you know, not throw
away somewhere that becomes
an English a still life.
So the two poems juxtaposed
to each other are recognized this,
the presence of debts,
but also the continuance
of life through the preservation of color
and in paintings, and then sonnets.
- Great, thank you.
Thanks for the question.
Thanks for sharing your thoughts.
The next one, we'll go
through this from Shivangi
really great question while
translating that your life world
and your own positionality
impose or interfere
in the way you interpreted
and translated his work.
And I think we can kind of
piggyback off that question
to do just think about larger
methodologies of translation.
I think...
What is it about your own,
you know story history that kind of a,
perhaps drew you to Sarduy and how do...
How does your, you know,
your own perspective sort
of figure into the ways in
which you translate that?
- You know, I think
that's a really important
and ethical question, right.
But I have to consider
when I'm, thinking of
how to render someone else's work
and it's whenever in English.
And so I think that's really central
and in the work of translation
and it's one of the
questions that comes up
in a I'm teaching a
translation course this term.
But so, yeah, I think
it sort of necessarily
does restrict my ability
to perfectly translate
a piece of work in the
way that it was written
in the original language.
So I think, yeah,
for what I came to his
works in a very sort of...
I guess it kind of
nautical training, right?
I was reading about his
work through the Canon
as I was getting my
master's degree in Spanish
at the university of Virginia.
So immediately, you know, I,
my understanding of the works
were what sort of historicized
and understanding him already
within a large amount of
criticism behind them.
But also I'm was trying to
place his works in conversation
with lots of texts that
I didn't know existed
as in conversation with those poems.
I think both my education
and my lack of sort of contemporary
the moments in which she
was publishing the words
from parents not really
from a university system,
but through in journals and these very...
And these publications that
had really small prints.
I wasn't reading them in the ways
in which they were initially published.
So I felt sort of constricted by that.
And, I'm not Cuban.
So I felt limited initially
by my understanding
sometimes of Cuban idiom.
So I shared poems with others who might
like have a different perspective
because I wanted to balance my limitations
with sort of the
perspectives and backgrounds
and readerships of others who might have
different backgrounds.
Who might hear things differently.
As I initially did when I
was reading that first on it,
but I discussed.
I'm sure I'll find even more
really fruitful conversations
about the ways in which Sarduy's poems can
and should be done differently
and translated differently.
And I think that's what Sarduy
with the flooded as well.
- Yeah. and I think, you know
what's really useful about
what you're sharing is,
you know it goes against
the idea of translating
between languages is like a
dialectical process, right?
It's really rather a lot
comes to bear, right?
And, I think in the
case of Sarduy's poetry,
you know, you are already
counting on excellent
translators of Sarduy's pros,
to be able to engage with and
a larger obviously community
of scholars of Sarduy's
work as well, right?
So it's very interesting
how all of those kinds
of points of contact
have to be marshaled or deployed
to be able to approximate
these translations.
- Yeah.
- When I gonna Adrian Adams.
Thank you Adrian your question.
Could you speak more
about how Sarduy's AIDS
related deaths shaped the
posthumous circulation
of his work within both Cuba
and international circles.
Which circles took up and...
or disregarded certain
elements of his repertoire?
- Wow, that's a great question.
(laughing)
I think when I think about that question
that the first text that comes to mind is
Pajaros de la playa which
came out soon after his death
in 1993, beach birds.
And it was translated
by Suzenne Jill Levine
and I believe also Carol Maier.
And in that text is
really very much about...
It's about an unnamed Island on which
as young men are dying premature,
like an unnamed disease.
And it's a beautiful book.
It's much more, I would say
the pros is much more...
I don't know, accessible in a sense
compared to his earlier (indistinct)
but incredibly haunting at the same time.
And it's impossible not to think
of AIDS and also Cuba.
And so when I think of that question,
I think very much about how Sarduy
was conscious of the fact
that he was about to die.
Many of his writer
friends had already died
like when we had died,
Reynaldo Arenas had died.
And he was trying to write the story
of imminent passing
that had no resolution.
And I really view this novel
as it has a beautiful rendering
of that inevitability
and also a tragic sort of
telling of how he viewed his departure
from the world and as a writer.
So I see that very much
embedded in the novel,
but also as you can see in the epitaphs.
I think they deserve a lot more attention
because it's obvious
that he's talking about,
he's writing into the epitaphs
with the word Sevadal in
Spanish, his own name.
And it's sort of like honoring the fact
that his name will be written into poems
about someone's passing someone
who happens to be severe
and will be recognized through that.
And at the same time
in a very sort of like
in a fun celebratory way right?
He's, off to dance at
the end of that poem.
So, yeah, that's how I see them.
I wish that I had the tops were more red
and more situated, but maybe
this will do some of that work.
- Great, thank you.
And thank you everybody for your question.
David I guess just kind of
before we wrap things up,
is there something you'd
like to share about,
you know what would you like us to know
about Sarduy's poetry or the point.
What should we leave here with,
or some things that delight you?
Perhaps, I mean I think that's something
that came through in your translation
and the way you framed
it was sort of, you know
not just the severe aspects of his poetry,
but rather this with and humor and irony
that was just, you know, incredible.
I guess any time your
final thoughts you'd like
to share with us,
about what we should be
thinking going forward
when we all buy your book and read it?
- I love that question.
I think of Sarduy as a playful,
brilliant poet and going forward,
if you can take one
thing with you is to sort
of remember him, not only as a novelist
but as someone who's
musicality, his love of jokes
his love of dance, his
love of food and pleasure
can be experienced through song.
And so if you can honor him in one way
to enjoy is the music of his poetry
in Spanish or in English.
And to take part in this process
of constant deferral of meaning,
I will not let you know exactly
what this poem is going to mean
but you can take more out of it
the more you read it,
the more you participate
in the act of reading and
reading out loud his poems
and in celebrating him the more
the more will be the nutshells
of his own desire to write and to love
and to sing will be remembered.
So to celebrate his poetry
and take that with you.
- That's beautiful.
What a beautiful tribute as is your book.
And so, congratulations again
if the public could please join me
and blotting David's
book, congratulations.
We really enjoyed.
I know I did.
I know we all did this very
wide ranging discussion
on a very complex and important
writer monopolous poet.
And so we just like to remind everybody
that if you know people
that would be interested
in this event and weren't able to attend
this will be put up on our YouTube page.
I believe that link was sent out
to everybody just a
moment ago in the chat.
So please spread the word, pass it along
and it will be made available soon.
And so with that
I would just like to thank
everybody for attending.
Thank you, David, the organizers
everybody who helped get the set-up
up and running so smoothly.
There's the link again in the chat.
Thank you very much.
We are ITM and yeah, everybody take care
and congratulations again
to David for the book
and for sharing his thoughts
on Sarduy's with us.
- Thank you, Shawn.
- Thank you.
- Goodbye everyone.
- Goodbye